sep tember 2014 it's the month scores of
game players associated with destiny the
long-awaited online shooter from Bungie
that commanded people's attention for
months before release who could have
suspected that Destiny's quality would
have been bested by a number of games
each of them worth playing in their own
right well perhaps it comes as no
surprise that a super smash brothers
game would be terrific but a dynasty
warriors off shoot featuring Legend of
Zelda characters not everyone would have
assumed the greatness of Hyrule warriors
and so we're grateful for these games as
well as the others that gave us
continued reasons to love games of all
sorts the vanishing of Ethan Carter we
love you for being so beautiful and for
giving us a mystery worth getting
invested in wasteland 2 we love you for
reminding us that old fashioned games
don't have to feel just plain old from
Phoenix rage to round about the gifts
kept piling up in September though if
there were piles to truly associate with
last month they are the piles of orcs
that continue to accumulate when playing
middle-earth shadow of Mordor indeed it
is to this Middle Earth adventure that
we grant our coveted game of the month
award for September 2014 it will be easy
to dismiss shadow of Mordor as
Assassin's Creed in the Lord of the
Rings universe but it's so much more
than that the Nemesis system turns the
game into a political party simulator
that allows you to play the call Rove of
the awk world one by one you turn or
acai against each other manipulating the
captain's into overthrowing their war
chiefs and proving that the most
dangerous warrior is the one who
manipulates minds as well as daggers of
course when you stick to murder /
manipulation shadow of mordor is still a
delight every captain arrived with Great
Hall blue claiming to be unkillable and
prepares to rip out your heart and eat
it how satisfying then to rip through a
couple of dozen grunts before jamming
your blade into their leaders neck and
watching his severed head fly through
the air shadow of Mordor is fun but it's
also more than that it's proof that big
budget games needn't be linear
and cinematic to be exciting in fact
roaming middle-earth as a ranger Wraith
hybrid and watching the orc hyland of
your courage and murderous deeds is one
of the greatest thrills we've had all
year and it's those thrills allow us to
call middle-earth shadow of Mordor
gamespot's game of the month for
September 2014